sie sagen das was da jetzt auf
europäischer Ebene verhandelt worden ist
ist placeazbo als Christina Dunz gerade
sagte ich glaube an diese europäische
Lösung und bitte nicht missverstehen ich
würde es auch so gerne daran glauben
aber ich höre das so häufig und dann
kommt jemand wie Herr Knaus und sagt
vergisset wird nicht funktionieren das
schit mus kommen er sagt er sagt das
scheitert am
Realitätstest wie ist das gemeint also
ganz einfach um diese Lösung die im
Herbst 2020 vorgeschlagen wurde von der
Kommission war von Anfang an total
missglückt und was jetzt verhandelt
wurde die letzten drei Jahre wenn das
nicht angenommen wird ist es besser für
alle weil das wird die irreguläre
Migration in keiner Weise reduzieren
also dieses Bild das in der deutschen
Debatte entsteht Opposition sagt die
Regierung muss das gut verhandeln die
Regierung sagt ja es schlecht ein
Durchbruch die die Grünen sagen wir t
schwer damitnd die bundesinnenministerin
sagt das ist historisch historisch das
ist alles wenn man sich es anschaut ich
gebe ihnen einfach nur ein Beispiel dass
alle Zuschauer verstehen die es gibt
Grund zwei Grundideen eines ist
verpflichtende grenzverfahren und das
zweite ist irgendeine Form von
Verteilung der Einstieg in die
Verteilung beides total total placeazbo
der der Kaiser ist nackt hat keine
Kleider warum die verpflichtenden
grenzverfahren kann man heute schon
überall machen die Griechen machen sie
Italien könnte sie machen warum macht
Italien für die die über das Meer kommen
keine verpflichtenden grenzverfahren in
diesem Jahr sind 50.000 Menschen in
Boten aus Westafrika in Italien
angekommen in diese Länder gibt es keine
Rückführungen Italien macht keine
Rückführungen nach ginea nicht nach
elfenmeinküste nicht und übrigens
Frankreich im ganzen letzten Jahr hat
Italien 200 Rückführungen in Länder
subsahara Afrika 200 200 da Ägypten ist
auch schon schönes beten im letzten Jahr
21300 Menschen aus Ägypten nach Italien
im Boot Rückführungen nach Italien ich
habe jetzt Eurostat sagt mir 300 oder
150 die sagen 300 also nichts es kommen
21 000 Rückführungen 150 200 also quasi
nichts qu jetzt würden die Italiener
sagen okay jetzt machen wir ein
verpflichtendes grenzverfahren die
großartige Idee der EU der historische
Durchbruch in 12 Wochen entscheiden wir
dass diese Ägypter keinen Schutz
brauchen ja das wissen Sie jetzt schon
für fast alle aber dann bleiben sie im
Land genauso ist es also ist die Frage
warum macht Italien stimmt dann zu weil
die grenzverfahren nicht an der Grenze
stattfinden müssen lesen Sie den Text
sie können auch in Mailand stattfinden
sie sollten an der Grenze stattfinden
müssen aber die Zentren sind auch nicht
geschlossen da gibt's den den Vorwurf
der Menschenrechtsorganisationen Achtung
eingesperrt Italien wird niemals die
Rede ist vom Gefängnis 50 000 Leute an
den Grenzen einsperren natürlich nicht
wir haben das gesehen Lampedusa da
kommen 5000 Leute dramatische Szenen die
Leute sindind eine Woche später schon am
Festland na ja die Bilder halten wir
auch gar nicht aus als ges he das erste
ist und natürlich ist es in Europa
verboten Menschen durch unwürdige
Behandlungen geschlossenen Zentren ab
das heiß das würden Gerichte sofort das
würde sofort das heißt die Kernidee
dieser Reform ist ein blöff und das
zweite ist die Verteilung die Verteilung
in Europa die durch diese Reform kommt
da geht's um ein paar tausend Menschen
die so stellt man sich das vor in
Deutschland undo sagt okay die sind
jetzt dann in Italien die werden dort
festgehalten in diesen Zentren dann
verteilen wir sie in Europa im letzten
Jahr nur für Italien italien hatte
ungefähr 80.000 Asylanträge Österreich
110 000 die W sagen wieso sollen wir aus
Italien Leute nehmen Italien hat im
letzten Jahr 25 000 Menschen Schutz
gewährt Deutschland ungefähr 130.000 die
Deutschen werden sagen wieso sollen wir
den Italienern Flüchtlinge abnehmen wenn
die ein Fünftel des Schutzes vergeben im
letzten jah hat Polen zehn Mal mehr
Ukrainer aufgenommen als Italien die
Polen werden sagen mit einer Milli fast
also ein Million Ukrainer wieso sollen
wir wir haben gemeinsam beschlossen wir
nehmen Ukraine auf in der EU und das
Ergebnis ist Italien Frankreich und
Spanien haben zusammen weniger Ukraine
als Tschechien man kann auch noch andere
schöne
Zahl frankreich hat ungefähr 70 000
Ukrainer allein BadenWürttemberg
ungefähr 170 000 das muss man sich
einfach n mal klar machen und warum
warum ist das so da ist eine bewusste
Entscheidung getroffen worden und
darüber müssen wir reden das sind die
Zahlen und das ist ja das ist die
europäische Lösung die wir wirklich
brauchen mein Vorschlag an die
Bundesregierung und wir haben es kurz
vorher
besprochen mit der neu nein nein ich
weiß aber es
wäre nein nein ich meine im Deutschland
im deutschlandpakt der vorgeschlagen
wird wenn da die Koalition ich glaube
das ist extrem wichtig dass wir jetzt
eine Einigung haben die solide ist und
die etwas bewirkt für alle
demokratischen Parteien und ein Punkt
weil das ist ja das das wichtigste wir
führen eine Debatte über Asylsuchende
das ist wichtig aber die der Grund für
die größte flüchtlingskrise der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik sind
natürlich die Ukraine und wir haben
keine Ahnung ob in diesem Winter noch
mal 500.000 nach Deutschland kommen das
liegt am LAF des Krieges und nicht an
Deutschland wenn aber dann die alle nach
Polen die baltischen Staaten die voll
sind die haben mehr aufgenommen als
Deutschland pro Kopf Tschechien Slowakei
und Deutschland kommen und niemand über
den Reihen nach Frankreich weil man in
Frankreich als Mutter mit Kind nicht
leben kann da ist man wird man behandelt
als asylsuchend also in einem
flüchtlingszentrum da kann man sich
nichts mieten dann sagt natürlich die
ukrainische Mutter mit ihrem Kind wenn
ich jetzt ein Jahr in Frankreich in
einem ölzentrum bin und in Deutschland
kann ich mir eine Wohnung mieten ja dann
bleibe ich in Deutschland gibt sogar die
Bewegung zurück aus Frankreich frreich
sinkt die Zahl Frankreich sinkt die Zahl
und die Ukrainer gehen zurück nach
Deutschland einfach mal Beschreibung der
Realität genau und daher ein konkreter
also zwei konkrete Vorschläge für die
Kontrolle denn wenn wir die nicht haben
dann werden bis zu den
europaarlamentswahlen und wir sehen das
ja in Österreich wenn man nur über
Migration redet intensiv aber nichts
passiert was Leute sehen als Ergebnis
dann kommen die Rechtsextremisten und
Rechtspopulisten auf 30% zwei Vorschläge
einen Fond auf europäischer Ebene die
neue polnische Regierung Deutschland
können es gemeinsam vorschlagen es gibt
eine Entscheidung gemeinsam aller 27
Regierungen für die Aufnahme der
Ukrainer warum gibt es keinen
gemeinsamen Fond der die Länder und die
Gemeinden unterstützt wo die Ukrainer
dann sind beim Aufbau von Infrastruktur
zweites warum redet die Kommission und
auch der deutsche Bundeskanzler nicht
auch Frankreich die Ukrainer werden auch
positiv gesehen wenn da 300 400.000
wären nicht 70.000 das würde die
deutschen Kommunen auf eine Art
entlasten wie nichts was wir im
Asylrecht machen und das nächste Asyl
die Opposition hat gesagt Herr Söder
zuerst Zielwert 200 000 jetzt wurde das
angegriffen we aber er er war natürlich
klug her Söder klar gemacht das ist
natürlich kein rechtlicher Begriff
natürlich kann man nicht Leute abhalten
na auch schon einmal durch mit her das
geht natürlich aber dann gab's eine
ideologische Debatte zwischen der
Regierung und und der Union die
Regierung hat in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
2021 gesagt wir wollen die irreguläre
Migration reduzieren reduzieren in dem
Jahr gab es in Deutschland 190.000
asülanträge also ist die gleiche Zahl
mhm wenn Regierungen Koalition und und
Opposition jetzt also die demokratischen
Parteien jetzt sagen würden unser Ziel
ist im nächsten Jahr 200.000 Asylanträge
nicht als rechtliche Grenze das absurd
als Ziel dann sieht man sich das an dann
sagt man wie reduzieren wir die 25 000
Asylanträge im letzten Jahr aus sicheren
Staaten Westbalkan vor allem Georgien
Moldau das ist keine Verletzung von
irgendwelchen Menschenrechten das kann
man machen durch schnellere Verfahren
die Länder sind alle bereit ihre Bürger
zurückzun dann sind 25000 weniger 25 25
000 ist viel ne dann welche Art von
migrationsabkommen brauchen wir der
Kanzler sagt auch jetzt wieder wir
brauchen migrationkom müssen se weil un
sonst die Zeit davon läuft er einmal
kurz Paul Z und dann habe ich noch zwei
konkrete Fragen noch mal ich habe ja
gerade meine Position sie haben ja auch
viel dazu geschrieben und dafür bin ich
dankbar ist mE Hel Klaus zuzuhören also
meine Position habe ich auch noch mal
dargestellt und die wird wird ja auch
von von meiner parteius ver wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass die Zahl nach unten
geht und nach unten heißt wir wollen
möglichst illegale Migration in in die
Bundesrepublik vollständig unterbinden
aber gleichzeitig natürlich europäisches
und deutsches Recht waren und die
Menschen Menschen würdig behandeln und
das heißt das was ich gesagt habe vorhin
sie kommen an den Griechenland sie
werden menschenwürdig behandelt und Sie
werden unmittelbar zuur Prüfung des
Verfahrens in ein anderes Land wie die
Türkei gebracht so wie Großbritannien
das übrigens jetzt mit Ruanda versucht
unterwahrung unterwahrung unterwahrung
unserer Rechtsstaat das müssen wir doch
hinbekommen wir können uns jetzt nicht
hier hinstellen und im klein klein
wieder darüber utieren sondern wir
wollen selbst entscheiden wer zu uns
kommt und dann am Ende festlegen wie
viel Menschen können wir in Deutschland
aufnehmen und welche Gruppe wollen wir
aufnehmen und das ist eine souveräne
Entscheidung übrigens dieses Recht der
Frage wen wir in Deutschland aufnehmen
das haben wir auch nicht per se
abgetreten an die Europäische Union
sondern Deutschland ist ein souveräner
Staat wenn wir das ernsthaft so machen
wollen das meine ich verstanden zu haben
dann können wir das doch nicht machen
wenn die Menschen erstmal in Italien
angekommen sind das wird so nicht
funktionieren haben sie gerade
ausgeführt na ja das mE meine meine
Frage wäre
Tunesien warimmer so ein Land von dem
man sagt da brauchen wir Abkommen
brauchen mit der Türkei Tunesien war
eines der Länder Libyen ist ein anderes
Land wenn wir nur mal über diese beiden
sprechen über das tunesienabkommen
spricht so gut wie keiner mehr der
tunesische Staatschef hat kürzlich 60
Millionen Euro wenn ich das richtig im
Kopf habe zurücküberwiesen von den 108
28 die die EU gezahlt hat dafür dass er
Leute davon abhält in die Boote zu
steigen und zwar mit einem ziemlich
bitteren Hinweis versehen der sagte wir
wollen von euch keine Almosen und nichts
was irgendwie nach Gnade und sonst was
aussieht das heißt da ist offensichtlich
und erkennbar jemand mächtig sauer warum
ist der so sauer das tunesienabkommen
zeigt uns dass es nicht reicht ein
Etikett zu haben wir wollen
migrationsabkommen der Teufel und die
Effektivität steckt im Detail und so wie
das tunesienabkommen geschrieben und
verhandelt wurde hat man alles falsch
gemacht das was Herr Zim jetzt
beschreibt dass man sagen wir wir finden
einen sicheren Drittstaat der muss ein
Interesse haben zu kooperieren ja wir
brauchen nicht viele aber es reicht auch
nicht ein oder zwei wenn wir einem Land
etwas anbieten würden dann brauchen wir
zwei Dinge nehmen wir nehmen wir also
ich glaube Tunesien ist jetzt verbrannt
und wir haben einen Präsidenten der
wirklich rassistisch auftritt aber
nehmen wir nehmen wir Randa ein kurz
einm kurz bei Tunesien bleiben das gerne
mal verstehen weil da so viel drüber
geredet wird und dann ist die mächtige
EU ist da dabei und alle reden mit und
es werden ganz bedeutungsschwangere
Worte gefunden und dann tragen wir
unsere Humanität nach vorne und so
weiter dieses Abkommen mit Tunesien von
dem sie sagen da ist detailliert gar
nichts wie lange ist das wie viele
Seiten wir haben einen siebenseitigen
Text ich habe bis jetzt immer noch nur
siebenseitigen Text ein Memorandum sie
sieben und ich habe den immer noch nur
auf Französisch gefunden also der wurde
da im Mitte Juli beschlossen es gab im
Mitte Juni eine Erklärung Mitte Juli ein
Memorandum und das Interessante ist wenn
man das neben das eu-türkei Abkommen
legt das sind zwei Seiten extrem konkret
das tunesienabkommen das sind lauter
Formulierungen irgendwie wir wollen mehr
Mobilität mehr Unterstützung die wenn
ich das lesen würde als Tunesier dann
sag ich da krieg ich da ist nichts die
EU versucht mich über den Tisch zu
ziehen die EU sagt wir geben euch Geld
eine Milliarde war im Gespräch aber nur
wenn ihr Bedingungen erfüllt die
Tunesien sagt die erfüllen wir nicht
also das ist wir reden über Mobilität
aber das schlimmste ist wir wir haben
gezeigt wir sind verzweifelt also die
Georgia Meloni die italienische
Ministerpräsidentin Herr rütte der
niederländische Ministerpräsident und
die kommissionspräsidentin reisen
gemeinsam hin sagen bitte bitte helft
uns dann bieten wir aber nichts wirklich
an also nichts wo inunesien Leute sagen
das wollen wir oder wo der Präsident
sagt das hilft mir und dann sagen wir
auf die Frage wie sollt ihr die
irreguläre Migration
reduzieren nicht durch Rücknahme nicht
wie Herr zimesagt nicht wie bei der
eutürkeierklärung dass wir sagen ab dem
stichag kann man Leute zurückschicken
weil die Türkei dann sagt wir kümmern
uns darum dass sie sicher sind wir geben
ihnen Schutz oder es gibt Verfahren nein
das steht da nicht wir haben im Grunde
genommen in Tunesien gesagt macht
irgendwas super und und wir wissen ganz
genau was das heißt das heißt nämlich
macht es so wie libien so quält die
Leute spert ein und was die Tunesier
gemacht haben während der Verhandlungen
mit der EU haben sie begonnen Leute aus
Fax im Bussen in die Wüste zu bringen
und an in der Wüste im Sommer ohne
Wasser an der Grenze zu Libyen
auszusetzen deswegen wollte ich das mal
mal hören und vielleicht können wir das
mal es gibt Bilder dazu das ist glaube
ich aber Libyen in dem Fall vielleicht
können die Kollegen aus der Regie das
mal zuspielen ne das
warunze so also wer sind diese Leute das
sind Leute die werden einfach zurück zu
also die Tunesier die Tunesier haben das
Abkommen gelesen die EU sagt ihr stoppt
die Leute aber kein Wort wirklich wie
und die Tunesier haben dann begonnen
Leute aus der Hafenstadt wo die meisten
losfahren einzusammeln einfach Menschen
aus subsahara Afrika das war total
rassistisch die wurden nach der
Hautfarbe
ausgewähltin in die Wüste zu fahren und
dann auszusetzen und wir wissen ja und
das muss ich dazu sagen her Zim hat
gesagt das jetzige System ist so un
inhuman wir machen das ja seit se Jahren
in Libyen in Libyen werden Leute zurück
ü gebracht von der lübischen Küstenwache
eingesperrt hier in dem Fall das
Verrückte ist hier erschien die lübische
der lübische Grenzschutz als die humanen
die haben dann sich um die Leute
gekümmert in einem Land wo auch seit 6
Jahren Leute gequält gefoltert erpresst
ausgebeutet werden und deswegen ist es
so wichtig für ein Land wie Deutschland
wo die Mehrheit der Leute sagt wir
wollen Kontrolle wir wollen nicht die
meisten die da übrigens derzeit nach
Italien kommen kommen aus Ländern wo die
Asyl Anerkennung Chance seh gering ist
elfenmeinküste ginea aber vor auch
Bangladesch Pakistan Ägypten tunesia
übrigens auch wir wollen die Kontrolle
wir wollen nicht dass diese Leute im
Bote steigen wir wollen sie aber auch
nicht in ein Land zurückbringen wo sie
gequält und gefoltert werden das ist
illegal unmoralisch und gegen alles
wofür wir stehen warum greifen wir nicht
das englische Abkommen mit Ruanda auf
ein englisches Gericht sie haben es
gesagt hat das gestoppt aber die
Entscheidung ist wirklich sehr
interessant weil was das englische
Gericht sagt ist diese Art Abkommen sind
im Einklang mit Menschenrechts und
Flüchtlingskonvention wenn in dem Land
ein sicheres Asylverfahren gewährleist
da geht aber um Abschiebung ne da geht
um ab die Dänen wollen das ja
auch fr konkret ist in England bislang
einer in ein Flugzeug gestiegen und na
nach Kigali nach Ruanda nein weil und
das ist jetzt das spannende und das ist
auch das in der Debatte wichtige England
hat Gerichte die funktionieren ja die
nehmen die Menschenrechtskonvention die
nehmen die Urteile des
Menschenrechtsgerichtshofs die nehmen
die Flüchtlings oder antiolterkonvention
und sagen ihr könnt das machen wenn
sichergestellt ist dass die Leute die
ihr dorthinbringt dann ein faires
Verfahren haben und jetzt kommt der
Punkt seit vier Jahren bringt der UNHCR
die UN das
un-füchtlingshilfswerk Leute aus Libyen
nach Ruanda ist richtig aber die
Verfahren macht der UNHCR und deswegen
geht das weil der onhcr macht die
Verfahren die Leute werden human
aufgenommen
so und jetzt kommen wir zu dem Punkt
wenn wir den UNHCR dazu bringen würden
bei solchen migrationsabkommen in den
Drittstaaten wir was es seit Jahrzehnten
macht übrigens in vielen Ländern der
Welt die Asylverfahren zu machen für die
die dort hingebracht werden wenn wir
dann den Drittstaaten ein Interesse
geben nicht wie in Lybien nicht in
tesien das ist das ist der Schlüssel und
das könnten wir stellen sich vor wir
sagen ab dem 1 Dezember wer dann in
Lampedusa ankommt wird registriert wir
retten alle wir wir stellen nicht diese
Rettung ein wir verstärken sie aber das
Ziel ist ab einem Stichtag Leute in
sichere Drittstaaten zu bringen dafür
und das hat die Union auch vorgeschlagen
das machen die Kanadier so Kontingente
mit Flüchtlingen legal aufnehmen genau
genauso muss man das angehen und ich
will noch Aspekt
noching ich bin jetzt kürzlich aus dem
Libanon wiedergekommen die Menschen im
Libanon schütteln den Kopf über uns und
sagen ihr seid schlicht verrückt
geworden dass Menschen die auch zu euch
kommen die z.B auch dort Flüchtlinge
waren oder keine Arbeit hatten von euch
mehr Geld bekommen im Monat als sie ein
Richter in unserem Land verdienen könnte
und
ihr könntet mit dem Geld was ihr für die
Menschen einsetzt in Deutschland so viel
mehr Gutes für so viel mehr Menschen in
diesen Regionen erreichen und wir sehen
heute die Menschen nur die hier sind und
ich appelliere daran zu fragen bei dem
allen was wir tun auch die Menschen zu
sehen die zu schwach waren oder gar
nicht aus den Ländern rauskonnen die
dort noch zurück geblieben sind denn die
Wahrheit ist es kommen aus vielen
Regionen vor allem junge Männer und es
sind nicht diejenigen die die
schwächsten sind oder das Geld nicht
zusammenbekommen haben aber auch die
müssen wir wenn wir humanhandeln in
Blick nehmen würd gerne noch einmal kurz
Christina Dunz Fragen können Sie
nachvollziehen warumus diese europäische
Lösung so wird die nicht funktionieren
ich meine auch wenn man diese Bilder
sieht und gleichzeitig die Bilder die
wir gerade da aus aus der Wüste gesehen
haben von halb verdursteten Menschen ähm
und gleichzeitig feiern wir uns als
historisch wir feiern uns als human wir
feiern uns als ganz großartig wie wir
das jetzt alles in Griff kriegen muss
man doch sagen also das geht über den
Status der Floskel leider nicht hinaus
diese Bilder sind absolut beschämend und
das ist jetzt ja auch keine Erkenntnis
dieser Sendung sondern das wussten wir
ja als wir als wir das gesehen haben und
es war natürlich eine Doppelmoral das äh
ist
unstrittig ich finde es trotzdem
schwierig es der Art zu häxeln
und
nicht mit zu überlegen was doch
vorangehen könnte durch die die die
Sache auch mit den Schwächen die Sie
beschrieben haben ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen oder ja ich kann es mir
vorstellen ich hoffe es kommt anders
dass die Europäische Union aufgrund des
Drucks innerhalb konsequenter wird und
mehr zusammenrücken wird weil das was
wir in Deutschland erleben an Problem
mit Rechtsextremismus und Populismus und
AFD werden wir in Europa bei der Wahl
sehr stark erleben und ich würde davon
ausgehen dass ein Großteil der Länder in
Europa überhaupt kein Interesse daran
haben und deswegen ist meine Hoffnung
weiter da dass es eine dass das als ich
würde es nicht historisch sehen und es
hat viele Schwächen
und es ist
letztendlich nie eine gute Lösung weil
das was Herr zimjak sagt wir Geld in die
Länder bringen müssen gilt nicht nur
dafür Leute zu bezahlen dass sie
möglichst da bleiben sondern es ging um
eine Wirtschaftsförderung es ginge um um
zu verhindern dass die EU dick mit
Subvention für die Agrarindustrie
afrikanische Märkte tot macht dass wir
sowas stoppen dass wir eine gerechtere
globale Politik machen dass da kann man
das das Rat ganz ganz weit Spinnen und
das was sie an drittstaatenlösung sagen
ich habe da trotzdem nicht das beste
Gefühl dabei weil es auch so wirkt dann
sollen wir bezahlen halt dafür dass sich
andere Staaten darum kümmern auf die wir
ja was wissen wir denn dann was in
Ruanda passiert ein Staat wie Ruanda da
würde ich jetzt sowieso erstmal ein
bisschen zucken also ich finde das was
sie sagen hört sich logisch an und das
wenn es klappt ist es gut aber auch da
hätte ich nicht äh
wirklich ein Vertrauen und noch mal um
das was die Europäische Union oder
Europa betrifft um das
abzuschließen es ist ja ein
innereuropäisches großes Problem wie mit
Ungarn und Polen Verfahren wird und
umgekehrt solche Länder mit der EU und
da muss es auch einen Gleichschritt
geben und ein Gleichklang das muss
harmonisiert werden da muss es eine
Einigung geben dass es nicht ein zwe D
Länder gibt an den es am Ende hängen
bleibt und die anderen sagen wir zahlen
nicht und wir nehmen keine auf und so
richtig Druck isteht auch nicht oder
dafür dass wir kein aufnehmen zahlen wir
20.000 € und dann ist auch auch auch
schon wieder gut das ist ein eine
weitere
Feinheit in diesem ganzen Vertragswerk
letzter Satz für Rian
alschebel wenn sie das alles so
hören vielleicht kann man das mal in 3 4
5 se Sätzen sagen wie würden sie es
machen abschließend gefragt also das
Problem das ist wier
das also ganz deutlich aber auch in
Europa wir viel zu lange Z Debatte so
über Bekämpfung der Symptome führen also
aber keiner redet über Bekämpfung der
Fluchtursachen ja machen wir schon aber
es halt nicht so einfach es ist nicht
nicht einfach aber also findet findet
meiner Wahrnehmung nach ziemlich wenig
statt also jedenfalls also haben sie
auch recht ja erzählen uns das immer
machen ist aber nicht das ist auch
wieder W ich wer ich werd a so die also
dieichtung grundsätzlich auch
unterstützen indem man sagt man wir man
wird praktisch eine Lösung finden wo man
Menschen Leben rettet aber gleichzeitig
hier die Infrastruktur vor Ort entlastet
das wärestbenswert keine Frage
aber noch mal die Frage um Menschen die
bereits da sind und lange und in einem
Land wo Fachkräfte an allen Ecken und
fehlen da würde ich noch viel lieber die
Debatte führen wie wir da ver
wir vorgehen das das das passiert ja
auch da bewegt sich was habe ich das
Gefühl und ich bedank mich sehr für eine
intensive Diskussion das war in
vielerlei Hinsicht sehr sehr spannend
ein ganz neuer Blick auf dieses riesige
Thema und Paul Zim heute so viel Glück
gehabt keine Frage zu Friedrich Merz ist
unorstellar sie hätten jede Frage
stellen können wird der
Kanzlerkandidat ich glaube die Debatte
hat jetzt ernsthafterweise gezeigt dass
wir jetzt habe ich noch mal so Markus
siet ich hab sie provoziert aber
ganz ehrlich wir diskutieren auch diese
Fragen es gibt ja ein klaren Zeitplan
ein Jahr vor der Bundestagswahl ich
glaube die Menschen hätten auch kein
Verständnis wenn wir das jetzt
diskutieren würden wir haben so viel
gerade in diesen aufgewühlten Zeiten mit
so vielen Krisen weltweit aber auch bei
uns in Deutschland wir haben richtig
jetzt zu arbeiten Regierung und
Opposition und das machen wir eine
allerletzte Frage habe ich noch
colambomäßig werden sie lieber
Generalsekretär vom Kanzlerkandidaten
märz oder vom Kanzler Kandidaten wüst ne
ich bin es gerne weil wir in der weil
ich in weil ich weil ich in der CDU bin
und das Schöne ist sie gerne das Schöne
ist dass ich mich mit beiden sehr sehr
gut verstehe und die beiden sich auch
gut verstehen die beiden verstehen Sie
auch richtig gut richtig gut ja okay und
als Friedrich Merz neulich laut über die
Überfüllung von Zahnarztpraxen
nachgedacht hat Füllung ist auch ein
schönes Wort in dem Zusammenhang über
Überfüllung äh da wie wie fanden sie das
ich finde wir sollten das was er
angesprochen hat darüber sehr ernsthaft
zu sprechen den mus selber tun muss auch
selber ernsthaft sprechen und nicht
falsches Zeug erzäh Moment Moment Moment
Moment es geht doch um die Frage welche
Sozialleistung für Menschen auch
übrigens die hier abgelehnt wurden als
asylber er hat ein Punkt er hat ein
Punkt angesprochen und meine Rückmeldung
sind auch die dass unglaublich viele
Menschen sagen da hat Punkt darüber
müssen wir sprechen ich ich fand sehr
interessant sie haben im Kölner
Stadtanzeiger das hat mir so gut
gefallen deswegen habe ich vorhin gesagt
das ist fast wie eine politische
Wurzelbehandlung sie haben das dann
übersetzt ich s sie sie haben gesagt ich
verstehe diese Aussage von März so dass
wir Zitat auch über die Grenzen der
Leistungsfähigkeit unseres Systems
sprechen müssen was richtig und was
wichtig ist was richtig und was wichtig
ist er hat ein richtigen und wichtigen
Punkt das heißt das wollte er eigentlich
sagen und das haben sie dann
dankenswerterweise den Kollegen vom
Kölner stadtanseiger mitgeteilt nein sie
jetzt drehen wir uns aber es geht doch
es geht doch darum dass die Menschen
dass die Menschen sagen welche Leistung
gibt genau welche Leistung gibt es und
ich sag ihnen wir diskutieren viel über
einzelne Worte Siek und dann wird
schnell gesagt ja W hat den Friedrich
Merz anstatt über die Sache zu sprechen
und da das sollten wir tun